what food do you love I love my mom's
chicken tacos simple chicken and a
tortilla but you come to that dining
table and she has a spread of guacamole
and homemade salsa fresh tortillas pico
de gallo queso fresco and you were
bumping elbows with people just trying
to fill your taco it's a mess but
there's laughter and conversation flows
and every once in a while you can catch
mom leaning back
silent smiling because her family is
happy and fed and loved
that's what food is food is love and
today I want to remind you of that as
business leaders but as consumers I also
want to make you aware that food is
business my mom cooked dinner every
night and though I may not have liked
every meal at that table I never
questioned whether it was good for me my
mom loved me and the food she fed me
with a gesture of care taking from
infancy all of our relationships with
food are most influenced by those who
first feed and nurture us and over the
course of our lifetime were socialized
to associate trust with food but can you
trust every hand that feeds you for me
it would take a personal health crisis
before I discovered that no you cannot
that once I leave my mom's dinner table
food becomes a product and I have to
evaluate it like I would any other
purchase as I got older mom I went out
with friends but snacks at the grocery
store at the gas station at school and
yet I never stopped to question what was
in the food I was eating until my senior
year of high school when my mom showed
me my graduation photos I had gained so
much weight
I couldn't recognize my face my doctor
checked my BMI I was clinically
overweight I was one stage away from
obesity I felt helpless I didn't know
what to do I didn't know what to eat so
my freshman year of college I kept a
food diary and I started exercising
daily and I took my first nutrition
class and I learned that from calories
to chemicals what's in the food that I
eat is something I have to know before I
can make a healthy choice that
experience was 10 years and 25 pounds
ago and it's what inspired me to become
a dietitian and whether working to serve
kids in a school cafeteria or to
implement national nutrition policy in
the White House I take that experience
with me the simple revelation that the
majority of the food that I need is not
the majority of the food being sold to
me the grocery store does not have an
investment in my health and well-being
the way my mom did the grocery store is
a business products line shelves and at
the eye level of children they're meant
to reduce what's called the nav effect
kids baking mom and dad to buy that
sugary cereal and a year eye level boxes
covered with blues and whites and greens
and new feelings of peacefulness
tranquility safety making you think that
that bag is wholesome a healthy choice
and just as you've survived that grocery
store experience you get to the checkout
aisle welcomed by magazines claiming to
know the next great superfood or
condemning the next thing you should
never eat again these tactics frustrate
all of us in answering a simple question
what should I eat and as it turns out 82
percent of Americans are confused about
that question our struggle to eat well
has serious implications
one in three adults are overweight or
obese one in two children in this
generation will have diabetes at some
point in their lifetimes and diet has
surpassed smoking as the number one
predictor of death and disease in this
country the confusion reaches us here in
this room I've had conversations with
many of you dispelling the
misinformation about food
paleo sugar-free gluten-free all
reasonable questions in a landscape of
misinformation but today I want to give
you a more important insight a way of
thinking about food that I think can
frame any choice that you ever make
before a purchase and it's this we are
programmed to oversimplify the
complexity of food your brain constantly
seeks to conserve energy by eliminating
the challenge of difficult choices we
are especially acclaimed to do this with
regard to products that we want to trust
like food we choose easy mental routes
instead of complicated ones so that we
can defer our mental energy for more
difficult challenges for example we
choose fast food on our way home from
the grocery store we believe those
magazine covers or there's commercials
timed at dinner right when you're hungry
and order in we go every afternoon for
an afternoon pick-me-up grabbing a soda
when we repeat these behaviors your
brain forms a feedback loop that
eventually needs no decision making
effort at all in order to create that
behavior and what happens is your brain
goes from making active decisions to
forming habits now habits are 45% of the
behaviors you make every day and they
maintain your productivity they reduce
your mental exhaustion but in the realm
of food they jeopardize your health
they induced you to believe those
nutrition claims those products that are
so conveniently located with just the
right message at just the right time
begging to do your thinking for you do
you know the difference between a claim
and the truth turns out it could save
your health conscious eaters not only
make healthy decisions despite increases
in price and decreases inconvenience
they have significantly less incidence
of diabetes heart disease and cancer so
how do you become a conscious eater
it starts with committing to educate
yourself on what's in your food you got
to learn more to make the right choice
and you'll start to find meaningful
terms on the front of packages certified
and regulate regulated labels like
organic and you'll start to learn that
the word natural has no meaning you may
find that most differing in your
nutrition needs are met from fruits and
vegetables lean proteins water products
that you find on the perimeter of the
grocery store you may start shopping
less in the inner aisles and as you buy
those fresh foods you may be enticed to
cook them and you'll find that just a
couple of simple tricks like sauteing or
steaming open up a whole new world of
food choices you will become conscious
of your decisions you'll know what's in
your food you'll know whether it's the
right amount and you'll know where it's
from this is my hope my aspiration for
the nation that if each one of us makes
one more conscious choice our collective
demand will generate systemic change
across our entire food environment and
that our farmers and our supply chain
managers our manufacturers and our
grocers will respond with more
accessible
more affordable nutritious choices for
everyone because food is a business and
as consumers we have the power to demand
what we want with what we purchase and
as business leaders we have the power to
take advantage of this opportunity
healthy demand is already increasing 82%
of consumers want to see healthier
products from companies and 70% of CPG
sales in recent years came from offering
those healthy options we have the
opportunity to meet that demand we have
the opportunity to make the fact that
food is love and food is business a
shared value because that's who we are
we're business leaders and we're
consumers and we'll be making decisions
about the food we eat for ourselves and
for our loved ones the rest of our lives
and our choices today will shape the
food environment of tomorrow so today I
hope you remember as business leaders
that food is love and as consumers I
hope you remember the food is business
and most of all I hope the next choice
you make is a conscious one trust me
it's good for you
you